la corte de Suprema de Justicia de
mayoría conservadora empieza hoy a
escuchar argumentos del ejecutivo Es
decir de la administración de Joe biden
sobre las prioridades que tiene la
patrulla fronteriza las los encargados
de vigilar la frontera de Estados Unidos
con México las prioridades que tendrán a
la hora de determinar Quiénes son
deportados y Quienes no eso es lo que se
está en este momento debatiendo y
escuchando en la Corte Suprema de
Justicia qué prioridades van a tener
estos agentes fronterizos a la hora de
determinar a quienes puede demandar
inmediatamente o a quienes le da la
oportunidad de pues tener un proceso de
asilo en este país lo que argumentan los
Joe biden y Alejandro mallorca es el
secretario de seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos es que dada el límite de
recursos que tiene pues se tiene que
enfocar entonces la fuerza pública en
las personas que representan una amenaza
una amenaza para la seguridad de Estados
Unidos Esas son las personas que pues la
patrulla fronteriza y los oficiales de
la frontera tienen que enfocarse para
deportar y no al resto de inmigrantes
Texas y Luisiana sin embargo estados
republicanos pues han apelado y han
contrademandado esta decisión y estos
protocolos de que ha propuesto la
administración de Joe biden diciendo que
lo que quieren ellos es tener la
libertad la discreción de poder
deportar a cualquier persona que no sea
legal en este país Alejandro mayorca
dice que Estados Unidos Simplemente no
tiene los recursos para deportar a más
de 11 millones de indocumentados en este
país y hay que Resaltar que esta
decisión se conocerá en julio del
próximo año